he says I have many things to say unto
you but you cannot bear them now for
when he the spirit of truth shall come
he shall guide you onto all truth he
shall not speak of himself as he hearses
to speak and he says something very
important at the end he goes and he
shall glorify me so Jesus is saying he's
going to go someone else is going to
come but he keeps saying he keeps saying
he he he he he doesn't say Spirit he
says he when the spirit of truth shall
come now at the end he says something
very interesting he says that spirit I
mean that being he will glorify me now
let me ask you a question is there any
other religion put Islam to aide that
believes in Mary believes in Jesus
believe in his miracles believes he the
uh he's uh the the the um Messiah he's
the Messiah and we believe he's going to
come back there is no other religion
except Islam Islam is the only religion
that believes in Jesus believes in his
mother believe in his Miracle believes
is the Messiah and believes he's going
to kill the Antichrist you know the
Antichrist
C Catholics believe that exactly exactly
that too exactly so we believe Jesus we
believe if Jesus comes today we will
join his
army brothers and sisters it is the
winter season in the UK today in my
house my boiler broke and the house was
freezing cold my kids are wearing
jackets I'm trying to find heating and
as a father I'm trying to make sure my
kids my wife are warm imagine the people
around the world I'm working with one om
my brother say 100% donation policy
charity who are helping Syria Lebanon
and Afghanistan people who are freezing
to death intense brothers and sisters
donate whatever you can because today's
experience with me showed me Subhan
Allah how vulnerable we are and just
made me remember those people who are in
need whatever you donate guys even if it
is1 help those people in those countries
we believe our main belief is God is not
a man Christians believe a lot of
Christians believe that he is God Jesus
Is God by the way I know you guys don't
believe that a lot of Christians will
say to you you're not a Christian if you
don't believe the Trinity you know the
Trinity Trinity the Father the Son and
the yeah if you don't believe this
you're not a Christian so in that belief
system Jesus Is God they say Jesus is
God they say he's the son of God and
he's God we say that doesn't make sense
wait wait wait wait to be honest though
continue sorry I just wanted to add that
point yeah yeah
yeah no no I don't run I trust
him
the Father the Son spirit yes I forgot
the rest
English saying amen good so we are
saying the name of like father is God
yes the son yes why do you think this is
wrong we We believe We believe the one
who deserves credit is the father so
father is the main source of power why
he's here good including the others so
what that means is if he's here Jesus is
below him yes okay Christians main
Christians believe that no the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit are equal
they are equal the the father is God the
son is God the holy spirit is God they
are all not three Gods but one Gods so
the Quran came to say look God is not a
man there is no one except God there is
no other gods so Islam has come to say
there is one true God for example in the
Book of John
17:3 Jesus is speaking he's saying oh so
they may know you the one true God and
Jesus who you sent so he's saying so
people can know the one true God and
Jesus who you sent so we say as Muslims
that's that's the statement of a Muslim
because the Muslim says there is one God
and there is prophets that was sent do
you understand we we agree with that you
agree with that there is Jesus as well
good so we we as Muslims we have to
believe in Jesus so if we don't believe
in Jesus you cannot be a Muslim we have
to believe in you know Mary yes Maria we
believe she's the most righteous woman
there was four she gave exactly so as
Muslims yes we Muslims believe that the
other Prophet they came to prepare the
people yes so they came to teach the
peopleare so when Jesus came save us
good okay good so there's there's a few
things number one firstly we it's good
that we're in track number one you don't
believe Jesus Is God no that's good
perfect as Muslims we believe in Mary in
our Quran have you read the Quran before
Quran is our holy
book Muslim bible okay so in the Quran
we have a we have a whole chapter we
have a whole chapter in the Quran we
have a whole chapter the name of the
chapter is Mary Maria uhhuh because
she's a very righteous woman number one
what do you think what is her she is she
is a uh a righteous woman was chosen by
God she had a miraculous birth you know
we believe that was born by a miracle
how you explain he's not not normal what
does what Allah says in the Quran the
likeness of Jesus is the like the
likeness of Adam just how Adam God
created Adam with no mother and no
father Jesus was created with a mother
had no mother and no father so what
we're saying is if we're going to use
Jesus having no father we believe he's a
mighty messenger Prophet but we say Adam
had no mother no father so we don't say
one is better we say look God can create
in different ways four ways God creates
let me tell you first one he created
Adam no mother no father correct good we
are created with mother and father human
beings yeah good um Jesus was created
with no father how was Eve created We
Believe through the rib of Adam yeah so
this is God's Miracles ways of creating
different ways so we say Jesus like you
said they were preparing for Jesus's
coming good but what does you to say in
the Bible he says listen carefully he
says I have many things to say unto you
but you cannot bear them now for when he
the spirit of truth shall come he shall
guide you onto all truth he shall not
speak of himself as he heares to speak
and he says something very important at
the end he goes and he shall glorify me
so Jesus is saying he's going to go
someone else is going to come but he
keeps saying he keeps saying he he he he
he doesn't say Spirit he says he when
the spirit of truth shall come now at
the end he says something very
interesting he says that spirit I mean
that being he will glorify me now let me
ask you a question is there any other
religion put Islam to a side that
believes in Mary believes in Jesus
believe in his miracles believes his the
uh he's uh the the the um Messiah he's
the Messiah and we believe is going to
come back there is no other religion
except Islam Islam is the only religion
that believes in Jesus believes in his
mother believe in his Miracle believes
is the Messiah and believes he's going
to kill the Antichrist you know the
Antichrist cath Catholics believe that
exactly exactly believe that too exactly
so we believe Jesus we believe if Jesus
comes today we will join his Army
against the Antichrist because we
believe he's going to kill it did you
get it we accept all of that there is no
other religion Jews do you know what
Jews believe about Jesus do you know in
the talmud they believe Mary is a
adulterer they believe she had sex
outside of marriage and Jesus is the
baby we say this is blasphemy so we are
we speak against them they also believe
Jesus Is Burning is going to burn in
Hellfire in his own um feces if that
makes sense this is what the Jews
believe so we say as Muslims no we say
to the Jews you are dishonoring Mary and
Jesus so we speak out against them then
we come to the Christians and say the
Jews they dishonor Jesus the Christians
come and say no no Jesus Jesus Is God we
say listen don't go to two extremes
don't say he's nobody don't say he's God
we say in the middle Jesus is a mighty
prophet he came to tell us about God and
have relationship with God so Islam in
the N show is what worship God Alone God
is one he does not have Partners he's
not a man he's not a woman he's not in
the creation he's not a statue so we say
that Islam the Quran has been preserved
it's not like the Bible the Bible has
been corrupted the Quran is the only
scripture that has not changed in 1400
years has been memorized by Muslims yeah
but who wrote the Quran was the Quran
was revealed it's called the Quran yeah
the Quran is the Quran Quran Quran yeah
it yeah yeah yeah yeah Quran Quran quick
about Jesus
about the thing that I want to say to
you is that in Islam like he said we
glorify Jesus in the Quran it says that
Jesus is the blessed one yeah we bless
him and after saying the prophet's name
we always say like upon them be peace so
we always send praise to Jesus now the
Bible in the Bible it actually curses
Jesus says Jesus is the cursed one did
you know this so you know Paul you know
Paul so he says that Jesus is the cursed
one says he was cursed to take all of
our sins or what not but it calls him
the cursed one now the Quran curses
Satan and says Jesus is blessed the
Bible says Jesus is cursed that's very
so which one do you think is from God
and which one you think is from Satan
scared
[Music]
me sh to them I'm guess aware this no I
have never saw that so so look into it
and there I have no no reason to Li so
if if you want to find out but yeah you
can check Jesus is the curs in the Bible
now if you believe Jesus is the you
believe he's the son of God so you even
Elevate him more than us do you believe
God would curse his own son no of course
not now do you believe do you believe
took our sins he died on the okay so
here's the next thing here's the next
thing here's the next thing do you think
do you think it's befitting of Jesus
yeah you believe he's the son of God you
believe God will send his son to die
naked in the cross being lashed until
his skin is Ping off because he was
doing that for us he doing that for us
but I'm saying do you believe it's
befitting of him Resurrection
Resurrection he believed in that so he
didn't why why does God need to
sacrifice his son for us so we we we we
believe that nobody to die for anybody's
sins in Islam we don't believe that it
is God is just God is the most just you
know what it means Justice okay we
believe God will never punish anybody
his son daughter innocent person it
doesn't make sense for an innocent
person to Bear the sins of the entire
world it doesn't make sense number two
this is not something that was taught by
Jesus know where Jesus said I am dying
for your sins this is something Paul
came out with you know Paul and you know
who Paul was before Paul was a bounty
hunter Paul was looking for Christians
to catch and kill them a bad guy yes he
was a bad person then he said I was
walking one day and I saw Jesus it's
like Hitler telling me telling the Jews
yeah you know I had a I saw uh Moses I
saw I saw Moses they say get lost we
don't believe you you killed us now I'm
not saying people cannot change but what
I'm saying is in Islam we don't believe
this concept of blood sacrifice it's
like a vampire like I don't want to be
disrespectful but it's like oh we need
blood blood blood why does God need
blood in Islam We Believe something
simple we believe if you sin you repent
to God not to anyone else blood we want
blood why do you want why do you want
blood we have the free no we
don't men the men okay killed Jesus not
God who killed Jesus the men the men the
men the Jews the Jews killed Jesus yeah
but you said he was sent by God to die
for our sins but but is was he sent by
God or did these men kill him because
when God created the world and asked the
creatures yeah he gave us the free the
fre so when Jesus arrives to to the
Earth the word was already bad yeah God
cannot control everything we we are we
have free will if control wouldn't have
bad people no no we believe God controls
everything but we also have free will so
there's free Destiny but we also I have
a choice of doing this but which one is
my choice iish something here which one
is is higher our free will or God's will
which one is higher dep it depends
because depends God cannot control us
like he cannot say oh you're not going
to cross the street now and get hit by
the car but he can kill you but he can
kill you you're saying God can't do
that so if you're walking across the
road right now and you're about to get
hit by a car God can't say do you know
what that's not going to happen God
can't do
that my free will doing because then you
saying that when someone died cancer you
saying well God permitted that person no
of of course of course we say nothing
this is just that happens because we
because we are sinners because we've
been for a long time good good but you
know what happens the reason why Islam
came down as a final Revelation because
you have the Old Testament you have the
New Testament the Quran is the right the
Quran is the final Testament meaning the
following this concept comes from the
following because we are sinners and we
cannot stand in the presence of God cuz
God is Holy we need someone in the
middle this is why Islam came Islam came
to say listen you don't need any person
in the middle if you have sinned if you
have wronged turn to God and repent so
you don't need to go to a priest hey
priest I want to confess my sins the
priest has got sins why am I confessing
to a sinner that has sins so God says in
Islam it's very clear no blood sacrifice
nobody dies for your sin no one get
crucified you sin you repent so the
relationship in Islam is very beautiful
if I do a sin I say I am wrong oh God
forgive me so there's three conditions
number one you hate the sin number two
you stop the sin and number three you
try not to go back to the sin but even
if you go back to the sin 1 million
times you repent because God is the most
merciful and we believe in the Quran
every chapter except one says Allah the
most merciful the very merciful we
believe God is very merciful he loves us
he doesn't want to kill anybody for no
reason it's not fair for me to kill you
because of her if she's done the
punishment why are you dying so so we
say Islam is about mercy and that God
has come to tell us the final Revelation
and the Quran is preserved the Bible has
been changed these that you believe
about Jesus's resurrection is made by
men and the Bible tells you that if you
open your Bible there are certain
passages that will tell you this story
doesn't belong here it's made up but you
don't believe in res Resurrection no we
don't we totally reject spiritual no no
no but but the thing is in the Quran you
can still be spiritual in the Quran you
mean Jesus's resurrection or our
Resurrection no no no no no Jesus is no
no no do you mean another topic that
we're going to no no we believe we
believe in the resurrection not we don't
believe Jesus died for sins us we
believe no no no as Muslims we believe
we're going to die and be
resurrected we believe that yeah so we
believe we're going to be judged based
on our Deeds nobody's going to come and
say oh I believed in Jesus even Jesus
says in the Bible he says many on that
day on the day of judgment will say to
me Lord Lord did we not prophesize in
your name and in your name cast out
demons Jesus says get away from me I
never knew you like saying go away I
don't know you why is it saying that who
prophesies in the name of Jesus
Christians who cast out demons in the
name of Jesus Christians we Muslims
don't so Jesus is saying move away from
me I don't know you so we say that in
the in the Quran we love him too we
actually do as Muslims we have to love
him so so the thing is here is that in
the Quran it says that Allah God
Almighty asks Jesus did you tell the
Christians those people to worship you
and your mother besides God he says I
never said such a thing God you know so
God Jesus always praises the father he
always says the father's greater than me
the father's greater than all all when
they asked him when is is the hour he
said I don't know the father knows so
this shows what that the father is super
but you guys already believe that so I
would say look in a nutshell read the
Quran I came to Islam 11 years ago I was
not Muslim I know I look Muslim I don't
know what a Muslim I don't I don't know
what a Muslim looks like yeah yeah yeah
yeah no I came to Islam 11 11 years ago
because I was I was a um theist I
believed in God but I didn't believe in
any religion I started reading the Bible
and then I looked into Judaism Islam
Sikhism I spent three years my only
condition was any scripture that I'm
going to follow it has to prove is from
God the Bible being changed to me was
like I can't cuz it's being changed in
Al to and because they believe Jesus Is
God I said I'm not going to believe a
man like me is God I said no so yeah to
me it took some time but yeah I mean in
a that show yeah I don't know how to
answer your question I've got a question
all like all our conversation is about
us turning to Muslims or to believe look
I can't the conversation is yeah no yeah
I would I would no no it's a good
question no a good question look of
course I would want everyone to be a
Muslim however I don't control the
hearts my job and my duty is I convey
the message okay you hear
it because in the Quran it tells me
there is no compulsion in religion I
cannot force you to be a Muslim it's not
permissible my religion says no you talk
you explain thank you my job is done you
want to ask me questions here till
tomorrow I'm here at your service
however I cannot control your heart so
my job is to answer questions if you say
one day you know what it makes sense to
me like for me I have had many questions
about Islam before I came to Islam why
this why that why this I had so many
questions the more I learned the more it
made conviction for me so I accepted
Islam so the same with us we want you to
become a Muslim we believe it's the best
solution we follow Mary Mary for example
she wears the hijab she's covered up
Jesus was circumcised you know for it
they didn't eat pork they didn't drink
alcohol you look at them we are more we
are more Christians we are more
Christians than the Christians we follow
Jesus more we follow Jesus more look we
follow her more than more than you guys
more than the why why do you call God
Allah okay Allah means the true God what
that means is for example because we
believe that God is not a man he's not a
statue so the one true God is Allah he's
not a man he's not a woman he there is
nothing like Bo the same thing yes it's
it's yes it's yes you know what language
Jesus
spoke um Latin no he spoke aramic yeah
do you know how to say good in
aric yeah yeah it's very close yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah it is very close you know
that yeah how do you pronounce it I
don't know the actual
pronounce and the Jews they call him Al
yeah yeah yeah the Jews they call him Al
that's what say
hallelujah so so Jesus spoke the Aramaic
langage he didn't speak Greek the Bible
is translated in Greek and we call him
Theos Theos yeah Theos and another thing
why do you fast we we fast We Believe
many prophets fast as well but because
God told us to fast why because God
no just cuz I we used to work I us to
work with Muslims and they try to
explain to me and I okay there's there's
look there's anything that we do we do
because God tells us to do now if you
ask me what's the wisdom the wisdom is
number one two number one control
yourself number one number two to
understand the people who are poor there
are people who are like these are just
wisdom for example people yeah of course
people who don't look people who don't
eat for hours it's for us to understand
and get a glimpse number two appreciate
food look you can go and eat whenever
you like if I say to you you're not
going to eat for 24 hours oh my gosh
you're going to be oh my stomach Etc you
will appreciate food more you any next
time you have water and food you will
say thank God because water not even
water yeah but why get that I got I got
I got and train on top of that why why
do you need to not suffer but like go
through what like poor people girls to
understand then you can just have
empathy and like I I understand that I
feel sorry for that I do charity I help
when I can why why do I need to fast why
do I need to suffer while they are
suffering understand sometimes I'll let
him say sometimes for example like my
wife when she was given birth yeah my
wife my wife was pregnant yeah when she
was given birth I was there I can never
understand that pain but me being there
was like oh my gosh this is this is like
I my respect and love for her grew even
though I didn't go through the same pain
I don't know what pain she's going
through but the fact that I witnessed
that to me was a miracle and the fact
that she is half dead like some of them
die to me it makes me appreciate and
value her more because in order for us
to see what what is beautiful you have
to see ugly so to us is that we have to
go through certain stuff to appreciate
anything that you do like do you work I
what do you do I work in an office you
work in office Stone company no problem
construction no problem whatever you do
you worked your way say that they didn't
you didn't wake up and they gave you a
job good thank you you wish but again
the struggles that you went through
appreciates the job that you have today
exactly it's it's like Donald it's like
Donald Trump Donald Trump said my dad
gave me a loan of1 million a small loan
like you go a small loan if you go and
give someone everything you have a child
you will destroy them if you give them
everything they want you will destroy
that child but when you teach them
hardship they have respect they
appreciate they value do you get what
I'm trying to say that's how life is God
has created in a way there are stages in
you getting something Islam will keep
you humble because no matter how how
much you have you're still going to fast
Ramadan you're still going to put your
head on the floor and pray and pray to
God so all of these things it keeps you
humble as a person no matter how much
you have and the other thing is maybe
you can empathize with the poor you can
empathize with the with the uh uh with
homeless people whatever but going
through something like fasting you will
empathize even more do you get what I'm
saying so even if you have that little
bit of empathy that will increase it and
someone who has no empathy they'll
surely be taught a lesson and not only
that it has many benefits there were
studies that show in the Middle East
they have the lowest rates of because of
fasting because you know when you fast
your body I was planning on doing 3day
fast I do I 3day fast detox no it's
recommended you know what it is like
even now I eat I eat one meal a day one
meal a day one meal a day but it's it's
a good meal yeah so I have like about
about 18 18 hours you know why because
your cells renews itself when you fast
you know you know we are not created to
eat every day you know that our body is
not created to eat every day we think we
need to free course meal we don't need
to I promise you I used to in Ramadan
one Ramadan five years ago cuz I'm very
I I'm into my fitness i j i run so it
was Ramadan and in my head I was
thinking oh I'm fasting I don't know cuz
usually I run 5 kilm so that day I said
it's Ramadan I'll do 2
kilm how do you your muscles no no but
okay so I started jogging I was jogging
jogging I looked yeah it's like 2 km I
bro I still got energy I'm fasting I
haven't eaten for 18 hours I said let me
do one I did four kilometers and I knew
it's all in the head I run better I
train better I train better even when I
do boxing when I train I promise you I
train better when I'm fasting and from
now you know what I do anytime I train
today I went jogging empty stomach yeah
I train better I have more clear mind
when you fast exactly honestly you know
a lot of people they get scared of
Ramadan they think oh I'm not going to
be able to do the things I usually do I
swear to God Ramadan comes even me I've
done it for many years sometimes
ramadan's coming I'm thinking oh it's
going to be hard this that W I feel
amazing my body feels healthy I feel
energetic and whatnot of the time I
actually feel more energy during Ramadan
than before after but people
with ask for because they can't and only
thatw during the night to eat and yeah
but there also there are some Muslims
they they end up they they not putting
weight because when it comes it's not
good they eat everything like an animal
this not from the this not from the
tradition the prophet peace be upon him
he have a date something small yeah now
fasting exactly but fasting is not also
just not eating food the prophet
Muhammad said to us Allah God does not
need you is staying away from food and
water if you are going to start talking
ill you back bite swearing at people you
um pointless yeah yeah because God God
doesn't need you to stay away from food
and water if you are abusing your friend
if you are swearing at your mother if
you are cheating someone else God
doesn't need you food and water the main
thing is spiritual cleansing that's why
as Muslim men for example for us we
don't if if a woman is dressed in a in a
way revealing clothes we we we are not
allowed to look we we should Allah tells
us tell the believing men when you see a
woman dressed look away why we have
fasting we have in
the you do but you guys can drink water
you can drink water but I think not we
we have different beliefs cuz like
during Easter we choose something that
we really like and then we give we give
up during this time and then it's a way
and there there's a reason for fasting
in the Bible as well so you will
struggle when you're fasting so when you
struggle you get closer to God same TAA
we call it we call TAA getting closer to
God exactly because you claim for him
more when you struggle other than when
you
have exactly same same we use Ramadan to
get closer to God we should be always
but he wants us claiming for him yes and
that is there's a sweetness to that when
you do things for God when you're going
through struggles there's a sweetness we
call it the sweetness of faith when you
get closer to God your faith increases
that's why to me alhamd the best thing I
believe that happened to me is Islam
because I don't like I used to chase
like I'll be honest with you this place
I used to come clubbing here before when
I was not a Muslim I used to come
clubbing partying here every every every
week that was my life I was like a
western partying clubbing girls holidays
I never found happiness never when I
came to Islam when I came to Islam to me
if they took everything from me no
problem everything money everything as
long as I have Islam and my faith I'm
good and that is something where you
become truly free because all of us
think we're free we're not as women for
example one of the things that you guys
suffer from is the beauty industry look
this way L'Oreal cuz I deserve it I look
L'Oreal cuz I'm L'Oreal cuz I'm worth it
it's it's like sometimes sometimes we
see woman here dressed in mini skirt
it's freezing cold my hands are look my
hands are cold I see C now okay good but
what I'm saying is this are you truly
fre you guys don't seem like your
some people come and say like oh this is
freedom but how are you free if you
think about it do you choose to wake up
and say I want to spend 2 hours putting
makeup no you would prefer to come
outside with no makeup but because
there's pressure from other women in
society it makes you want to look a
certain way you know what trying say
yeah but if we get in that subject I'm
going to sit down and
then this person that person exem
feminist but I believe in thing about
should ever we want to do not because
I'm a woman because
you what we say is the
following in what sense if you are being
told what to think how do you have
freedom if you are being taught that for
example the values that you have for
example today is against Christianity a
year from now there's certain things
that Christian woman do is not
Christianity the way you dress I'm not
going to be worrying for example the
Bible says that your husband is the head
of the house Christ Christ ah see
exactly
but Christ is the head of the church and
the man is the head of the house even
tells you when you come to church you
are not allowed to
talk you should not raise your voice
over your husband that's the thing I
think the way Society raised us all
of is very sexist CU my parents are
sexist so but for a
while so I was raised in a way that I
didn't I start whatever you guys are
free like to wear clothes what I I want
you wear how I want you wear so now that
I'm a grow up like grow up woman I
believe I can do whatever I want to do
if I want to dress in a way I shouldn't
be judged by the way I'm dressing man
shouldn't look at me with the bad eyes
or whatever because of the way I'm
dressing as I cannot look at a Muslim
and I cannot judge them because they
wearing hij yes because their religion I
totally respect as I want they to
respect me doesn't make sense do make
sense but the thing is this we live in a
real world and when you dress up in a
certain way it's going to get the
attention of men I'm not saying I'm not
saying that a man has a right to touch
you no no no I'm saying the reality is
that as a man he's created with a desire
for a woman so when a woman dressed in a
certain way he wants to talk to you I'm
not talking about rape I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about he's going
to come and lie to you because he wants
you for one thing and he's going to give
you false promises and it's going to
break your heart that's why Islam says a
woman has a role a man has a role we are
not we are not the same we are equal in
the in the sight of God you are equal I
am equal however your responsibility is
different mine is different my job for
example with my wife is I'm the
protector and provider I'm a full-time
bodyguard I'm a full-time bodyguard when
I'm walking if somebody says something
to my wife I'm not going to I can't run
away I have to defend her so you see
when it comes to feminism with this
stuff for example you will understand
that I do it number two I have to
protect and provide for my wife my wife
have to pay for rent shopping Bill gas
electric petrol nothing I pay for
everything she has to be served why
because she's a woman she's vulnerable
she's weak You're Not Strong look you
are not strong would you agree that men
a woman is not as strong as a man
physically no way us you have to agree
that have to
that look right listen if I don't know
if believe in divorce you believe in
divorce yes we allowed to divorce yeah
so if your wife you are the provider and
you and your wife break up yes and
you'll say bye-bye who going to provide
her are you going to provide her Islam
says the following before I get married
um there's something called Mah Mah it's
a doy so argument let's say you are a
Muslim you marry a Muslim man before you
marry number one he has to speak to your
father okay because why because if he
has bad intentions with you your dad
will know a man knows a man so to
protect you because if he's after dating
and just sex to use you and run away he
knows he has to face the consequence of
your father number one number two you
have a right to ask for money any amount
again we live in the real world not how
it works no no no no it worked my wife
not in the okay in my world my wife she
asked for some money I don't want to
tell you amount it was okay okay why
because if I leave that's her protection
that money she on for example my parents
they broke up when I was two my mom had
work and live me with my grandparents my
mom found my stepfather Who provided to
the house whatever she helped him to
grow as a
like raised me and my brother he cheated
on her he left her and now she's
financially to pay the bills because she
was supporting him to get the money in
the house broke up so now now she's by
herself with my brother I'm here and he
has a lot of familiar
and then what left so that's why that's
why in Islam that's why Islam gives the
right for the woman to us for a money
that if this happens it's like a deposit
it's like a security so she keeps that
for example £10,000 she says you want to
marry me my m is £10,000 he has to do a
wedding he has to give her that money
that's her money he cannot touch that
money you know the money I gave my wife
I am not allowed to touch that money is
that is her money I have to do shopping
all of the stuff I do okay good shees
work she doesn't have to work she can
work if she wants islamically she's
allowed to work but if she says no I
want to be with the kids no problem
which is good to her I'm happy with I'm
happy with that however if me and her go
are separate ways she has that money to
rely on number one number two if I go
her father her brother her uncles have
to look after
her has to so we say the men has to
always protect the woman because a woman
is V
she is weak in what sense when a woman
is a pregnant is she not weak she's weak
she has to be looked after
I'm exactly no no no no I'm not saying
okay okay what I'm saying is the
following when a woman if you are
walking down the
road two men come to attack you can you
defend
yourself I did my
time I can kick and run okay that's good
but what I'm saying is if two men are
behind you me and my friend we're going
to come and help you yeah of course okay
what was saying
is yes but I believe women are mentally
more stronger than men stronger so do
you see how God has created us you have
points where you need my help and there
is points where I need your help good
perfect that's what I'm saying so we're
saying we complete one another we're not
competitors do you get it because the
feminist World falls for the idea that
they want to be like man why do you want
to be like a
man you exactly perfect because a woman
you should enjoy it let your husband my
my wife go work look after me okay no
problem let her enjoy life let her enjoy
time with the kids because the family of
father and mother it brings a good
generation of kids healthy minded kids
divorces effect Society that's why Islam
has these protocols in place to protect
the man and protect the woman but
there's more there's many stuff to learn
about Islam but read the Quran I mean
yeah like you know just read it and
he said this that I just told you if you
believe
this man sat down for one
yearing something like he wanted to
prove he wanted to bring something I see
I hear you I because of what
happened you know why because because of
a bad man and I I understand are sadly
sad sadly sad and look
I true but a lot of men men a lot of men
they don't today men are not men and
women are not women and sadly this is a
reality that's why Islam believes in
Traditional Values a man does his job a
woman does his job Community flourishes
it's very good in theory but in
work it will but they don't follow
it yeah it was nice talking to you yeah
if you have any other questions let me
know I went to Brazil once sou Paulo
yeah I went like seven eight years ago
it was nice yeah I like Brazil cuz we we
as Muslims we are allowed to marry
Christians and Jews yeah and we could
but only Muslim men not woman Muslim
women cannot and I'll tell you why
Muslim men yeah yeah yeah I'll tell you
why we are allowed to eat Christian food
and Jewish food cuz we eat Halal Halal
hell but we can have Jewish and
Christian food the reason why as a
Muslim man I can marry a Christian or a
Jew but not my wife is because if I
marry a Christian woman or a Jewish
woman I cannot force her to become a
Muslim I cannot force her to accept my
religion however if my wife marries a
Christian man or a Jewish in their
religion they can force her to become a
Christian that's why it's to protect her
because because generally men when they
are leaving the house they can control
and manipulate so it's a protect her
from men as a Muslim man I'm not allowed
to force my Christian wife or my Jewish
wife to become a Muslim but a Muslim
woman she's weak he can tell her no
you're going to accept Christianity so
it's the protect her okay but both
Muslim man and Muslim woman we cannot
marry Hindus you know Idol worshippers
yeah both us we're not allowed to marry
Hindus hindia India yeah Hindu yeah but
Christians and Jews Muslims we live
together for centuries together because
we're very close in belief you believe
in God you believe in angels you believe
in herea we're very close Allah tells us
we are very close to the
Christian yeah when they thought the
Earth was flat he knows the universe is
expanded it was nice talking to you
thank you how long you guys here for
that's knowledge Beyond you live here oh
you live here oh good good good but
originally you're from
Brazil been here I been here for S years
years and oh wow
also that I leave you guys it was nice